[Music]  three days are going to conduct a trade  then just started falling need answers  fast  the first airfield tech rudder the  office interference I don't think you're  gonna fly me all the way out here for  the interference in the last few weeks  we've been finding buddies around the  city that were killed in the same way  look we work to keep our guys safe they  need your help  they're gonna get you close to  it's gonna be up to you to figure out  how to stop this what to take the shot  did you see that two bolts one right  through it  ten pull out right now  is anything that explains what you saw  No  there's no limit to how far they can  spread unless we stop  [Music]  are we gonna do it's a question of how  serious you are about seeing justice  done